now when Jesus learned that the
Pharisees had heard Jesus is making and
baptizing more disciples than John
although it was not Jesus himself but
the disciples who baptized he left Judea
and started back to Galilee but he had
to go through Samaria
so he came to a Samaritan City called
Sychar near the plot of ground that
Jacob had given to his son Joseph
Jacob's Well was there and Jesus tired
out by his journey was sitting by the
well it was about noon a Samaritan woman
came to draw water and Jesus said to her
give me a drink his disciples had gone
to buy food the Samaritan woman said to
him how is it that you a Jew ask a drink
of me a woman of Samaria Jews do not
share things in common with Samaritans
jesus answered her if you knew the gift
of God and who it is that is saying to
you give me a drink you would have asked
him and he would have given you living
water
the woman said to him sir you have no
bucket and the well is deep where do you
get that living water are you greater
than our ancestor Jacob who gave us as
well and with his sons and his flocks
drank from it jesus said to her everyone
who drinks of this water will be thirsty
again but o those who drink of the water
that I will give them will never be
thirsty the water that I will give will
become in them a spring of water gushing
up to eternal life the woman said to him
Sir give me this water that I may never
be thirsty or have to keep coming here
to draw water jesus said to her
go call your husband and come back the
woman answered him I have no husband
jesus said to her you are right and
saying I have no husband for you have
had five husbands and the one you have
now is not your husband what you have
said is true the woman said to him sir I
see you are a prophet our ancestors
worshiped on this mountain but you say
that the place where people must worship
is Jerusalem jesus said to her woman
believe me the hour is coming when you
will worship the father neither on this
mountain nor in Jerusalem you worship
what you do not know we worship what we
know for salvation is from the Jews but
the hour is coming and is now here when
the true worshipers will worship the
father in spirit and truth for the
father seeks such as these to worship
Him God is spirit and those who worship
Him must worship in spirit and truth the
woman said to him I know that the
Messiah is coming who is called Christ
when he comes he will proclaim all
things to us jesus said to her I am he
the one who is speaking to you just then
his disciples came they were astonished
that he was speaking to a woman and no
one said what do you want or why are you
speaking with her then the woman left
her water jar and went back to the city
she said to the people come and see a
man who told me everything I have ever
done he cannot be the Messiah can he
they left the city and were on their way
to him
meanwhile the disciples were urging him
rabbi eat something he said to them I
have food to eat that you do not know
about so the disciples said to one
another surely no one has brought him
something to eat
jesus said to them my food is to do the
will of him who sent me and to complete
his work
do not say for months more then comes
the harvest but I tell you look around
you and see how the fields are ripe for
harvesting the Reaper is already
receiving wages and is gathering fruit
for eternal life so that the sower and
the Reaper may rejoice together for hear
the saying holds true one sows and
another reaps I sent you to reap for
that which you did not labor others have
labored and you have entered into their
labor many Samaritans from the city
believed in him because of the woman's
testimony he told me everything that I
have ever done so when the Samaritans
came to him they asked him to stay with
them and he stayed there for two days
many more believed because of his word
they said to the woman it is no longer
because of what you have said that we
believe for we have heard it for
ourselves and we know that this is truly
the Saviour of the world
David this is one of my favorite stories
in the fourth gospel because I find it
so so richly textured and so finely
crafted and there are some things in it
that I know I first missed when I
started to read this gospel and I've
come to appreciate in in recent years
and the key thing I guess is the the
setting a well and it evokes stories in
the Old Testament of patriarchs going to
wells where they meet their future
spouses
so there's from the get-go in this story
a kind of erotic tension that's set up
between Jesus and the woman
and that's something I did not once
appreciate but I think it's there and I
think it's a very important part of how
this this story works but but it works
with the twist because in all those Old
Testament stories when you have the the
patriarchs coming to meet their spouses
or future spouses they are the suitors
and the women are that people being
pursued the sod whereas here it seems to
be the other way around Jesus encounters
the woman and gradually evokes a
curiosity about himself in her so she is
drawn to him and gradually reveals
herself in her own kind of checkered
history which he nonetheless accepts and
then in the process this this do blonde
tandra again this pun on water on living
water which would originally been water
that flowed right and Jesus claims to be
able to give that and it evokes all the
earlier puns and do blunt Andris that
we've seen with Nicodemus and with a
lifting up all of those word plays are
here again and the motif of water that
we talked about a little bit in
connection with a Nicodemus episode is
back here again well what's it pointing
to it's pointing to worship in spirit
and truth and that's where it finally
winds up so we have that SAPI an shal
motif the water there really is to be
understood at a deeper level similar to
something up and we have the erotic
motif between Jesus and the woman and
what's the connection between the two do
you have you thought about well yeah
I've thought about that because you sent
me thinking about it about four years
ago I think I had missed it for sixty
years before you wandered into my life
and confused the issue it seems to me
that the what reinforces the erotic
thing for me then I want to come back
and put you in a little bit is the the
way the disciples come back and wonder
what's been going on well they've been
gone this doesn't sound like just you've
been having an interesting theological
conversation but you've been talking to
the woman what does all this mean so I
think that that reinforces what what
puzzles me is if this is a kind of
parody or reversal or switch on the
standard
but the Whale stories what's the what's
the function of it I know how the how
the parody on creation works you start
with the expectation in the beginning
God and it becomes in the beginning the
logos you start with the word being what
God says now the word is incarnate here
we have what is very much like a
patriarchal setting and then suddenly it
switches around why why do we get it set
up that way mm-hmm good question and I
thought about that in a couple of ways
I'm not sure I have the the final answer
on that but two thoughts one has to do
with this business of gender categories
that we were talking about before and
the kind of preference generally
expressed in especially Greek
philosophical and even Jewish
philosophical sources for the male as
symbolizing the spiritual so to have the
spiritual somehow highlighted and
focused on through the person of Jesus
might be part of it might be part of
that general tradition another reversal
though one way I've tried to think about
this is to think about the way in which
love stories tend to be told in
antiquity or stories about love
relationships and some of them are at
the the simple level of boy meets girl
boy gets separated from girl and after
many adventures they get back together
lots of novels like that weren't in
antiquity but then they were sort of
higher level reflections on what love
and friendship are all about and John
later on will talk about friendship as
an important way of thinking about the
relationship between Jesus and His
disciples and the most famous story
along those lines was told by by the
philosopher Plato in his symposium and
that was picked up on later by Aristotle
and I think those two connections are
very important the story and Plato's
symposium has to do with the notion that
love is all about moving up a ladder of
being to a higher and higher level of
beauty and reality and finally you try
to capture that reality and then
instantiate it in your life and when you
do that you you actually live a life of
virtue when you try to be get off what's
absolutely beautiful you live a life of
virtue and at the end of the symposium
there's a story about a lover and to be
loved
and Plato of course was operating in a
society where it was a masculinity and
we're talking about male love
relationships here but they the
relationship between the beloved
Socrates and his love Alcibiades is the
same as the relationship between Jesus
and the woman at the well that is
Alcibiades is drawn to love Socrates and
Socrates refuses to have anything to do
with him at the physical level why
because he wants to inculcate in him the
life of virtue the vision of perfect
beauty so here to the conventions of the
traditional love story where a physical
relationship is finally consummated
between the pursuer they patriarchy and
the pursued his beloved new wife that
doesn't happen here relationship is
reversed the one who should be pursued
they woman becomes the pursuer of Jesus
Jesus holds off why in order to make her
something else now bring her farther
along that's right and what does she
become at the end of the story she
becomes his emissary to severe
Samaritans right they come to make their
confession in Jesus as the savior of the
world because she has told them that her
life has been explained to her by Jesus
so I think I think that's an important
part of the sinner was it I think I
found other ways of trying to do it
homiletically the it works with your
framework which is you've watched the
way in which her understanding of who he
is
deepens as the story goes on first he's
just a Jewish man and then he's a
prophet and then maybe he's the Messiah
and then finally at least what the
Samaritans come to believe on v-app
because they see him is that he's Savior
of the world which is that kind of
deepening of her own understanding of
what's going on and I think strengthens
your idea that this is this is a
spiritual deepening rather than a kind
of physical liaison at the end of the
day yeah I like that and it parallels
something that we see in a number of
chapters of John where there's a kind of
climactic arrangement of the
affirmations back in John 1 when the
disciples first being called and they
meet him at the end of each section they
affirmed something about him and there's
a
chain of those affirmations until Jesus
himself says something about who he is
which is kind of mysterious after one of
these son of man Zhang's John 1:51 so
there's a the same structure there and
we had that structure of affirmations
about who Jesus is as they the woman
comes to a deeper understanding but
there's what captures my attention is
the way in which her role and her
relationship to Jesus is transformed in
the story yeah so being focused first of
all on him she and personally and
misunderstanding who he is she
eventually becomes focused on how to
spread the word about him no it's very
very good
when when he says begins to say who he
is and she says I'm no Messiah is coming
what he says in Greek is egg away me
mm-hmm who is speaking to you and some
people think that that's a reflection of
the Greek Old Testament version of Moses
before God asking God's name and God
says I go Amy I am Who I am and some
points I think in John's Gospel Jesus
comes very close to kind of taking on
the divine name of Yahweh do you think
that's happening here you think that's
jumping the gun on that I think this
might be jumping the gun but I'd agree
that eventually there is an e vocation
that that self revelation of God by
God's name in the book of Exodus that we
find especially in John 8 yeah before I
am yeah the Greek phrase they go Amy
in so many cases can simply be a quiver
my right right oh it's me
yeah but in that case before Abraham was
pregnant early and I'm sure John is
beginning to play I wonder whether John
isn't leading us along - let's start
with say moi and move to Yahweh and if I
ease you into it by the time we hit
Yahweh it won't be quite so shocking
right I think that's that is reinforced
for me and in two ways one is at the
level of an explicit motif in the gospel
where in John 17 we have Jesus talking
about how he has how he has come to
reveal the name of the Father and given
the name to
the disciples and this is picking up on
a tradition in Jewish literature about
the significance of the divine name and
also picking up a practice in Jewish
scribal activity of referencing the
divine aim even in text of they the
Greek translation of the Old Testament
we had the word kurios a lord is used
for the instead of the divine yeah yeah
so all of that's lurking in the
background and that's one thing that
reinforces it for me the other is
getting back to my little love
relationship business and thinking about
how the woman comes to be attracted to
Jesus and therefore transformed yeah how
that parallels first of all what you
find in Plato it also parallels
something in Aristotle Aristotle's
notion of God is that the notion of the
unmoved mover mm-hmm that spiritual
being who surrounds and encompasses all
things and lives the most perfect of
existences which is to sit around
contemplating himself which is the most
perfect thing to contemplate sounds like
kind of narcissistic understanding of
God but it's it gives Aristotle the
mechanism by which to explain all motion
in the universe because everything else
in the universe is in sould somehow so
the planetary spheres that give the
university circular motion try to
contemplate and try to imitate that God
Aristotle has a a little phrase to
describe how the unmoved mover works
he keen a hosts a ruminant he moves as
an object of desire hmm Jesus in this
story moves as an object of desire he's
portrayed in in some way as Aristotle's
God and then he announces himself at the
end with this formula that I don't
really know we'll see taken is the
Hebrew Bible way of talking about God so
I think that's a very interesting
possible play that John is engaged to
themes that I pick up that I just want
to add to that one is her she begins to
sense who he is
because he knows who she is and moving
anachronistically I've always liked with
that the prayer from the Book of Common
Prayer
Almighty God unto whom all hearts are
open all desires known and from whom no
secrets are HID that the part of what
Jesus reveals of himself is that as
throughout this gospel he's the one who
knows and sometimes that's bad news but
sometimes that's good news and I think
she receives that as the beginning of a
revelation which goes even further and
the other thing is important that she's
a Samaritan and a woman
we've just had this Jewish not that long
ago in Chapter three we've had this
Jewish male who seems to sneak out at
the end of the day not quite getting it
and here we have a Samaritan woman who
is being lured at least toward a deeper
understanding of faith and Nicodemus God
mm-hmm and the Samaritans actually come
to consider actually coming up as savior
of the world all of that going on within
a text that also affirms that the
priority of Judaism and salvation all at
the same time salvation Jews in John
4:20 Joe and Bob we're coming to a world
where neither of those things right it's
gonna be the priority where worship in
spirit and in truth is going to define
who were they the children of God yeah
and then we're back to our old term
spirit that we had in Nicodemus and the
truth that we had in the prologue this
is another one of those episodes where
our friend Lou Martin sees an
interesting parallel with a historical
development of early Christianity and
sees there being some sort of
relationship with with that developed in
the way the gospel is structured if you
go back to the the book of Acts you
remember how things start in Jerusalem
and then they the Helenus go out and
convert the Samaritans so and we have
stories about Jesus either avoiding or
skirting Samaria in some of the other
Gospels here he's there he's in right
area so what was viewed as a post
resurrection development in Luke's
account of the story of the church is
embedded into the skirmish Jesus here so
we start with the Pharisees we move now
to the Samaritans eventually by the way
we're going to get to the Greeks in
chapter 12 yeah and so there's a kind of
structure of an ongoing and expanding
outreach of the the presence of the word
or of the light which have a metaphor
toward broader and broader and broader
yeah and also the way it begins it was
necessary for him to pass through
Samaria maybe that's like it was
necessary to pass through White Plains
in order to get here because that's
where the plane landed but maybe that's
because this is the
this is the necessary pattern by which
god is working out through Jesus this
thing that moves from Jews to Sumerians
to Greeks and finally God so loved the
world so Jesus is not just savior of
Jews or Samaritans but savior of the
world that universal claim which which
takes the particular claim and makes it
even richer and fuller right that hint
that we had way back in the prologue and
way back in the prologue now extending
itself out yeah it's interesting to
think about that in connection with our
conversation about the social reality of
of early Christianity that maybe somehow
in the background here there could also
be an intermediary step that is the
literary exploration and social reality
and so one of the things that John as a
gospel is trying to do is to sum up a
lot of early Christian literature that's
available to him part of that might be a
story of Christian origins the like of
which we have in Acts yeah and so he's
trying to actually this complicated
story in Jesus a single narrative yeah
and this reflects again that phenomenon
that we noted a little bit ago in
connection with theological emphasis the
phenomenon of a collapsing of temporal
horizons everything is here in this
little gem it's like a gem that you can
look at from different facets and see
the light refracted in different ways
it's all in the story of Jesus yeah so
this is another case where that the
medium is the message
yeah right John is taking this story and
loading it with extra layers of meaning
in order to make connections that
otherwise are made in different forms
yeah again Lou Martin talks about as it
has a as a play that actually has two
sets of actors there's the Jesus story
and there's a story of John's Church and
in some ways the figures represent both
those stories and then the churches
wanted to say our story - so this is
Jesus story church's story Christians
story all reflected in this kind of
amazing dialogue the other thing I want
to make sure we hold up because we
mentioned it already is the way the pun
the do blonde pounder works here which
is living water means to the first here
water in a stream I've come to a well
that's kind of a bore what about a
stream I could take that anytime because
it's always available but what he means
in this case I think is water that gives
life water the time after time is the
replenishment and then it becomes a
statement about himself not a statement
about
something he's discovered in the
geography and topography of the place
right and then we get to the issue of
where is that higher level of water not
only at the conceptual level right right
or is there some sort of sacramental
dimension somehow the background here -
I think the emphasis here in this
chapter at least is on the conceptual on
confessing and understanding who Jesus
is but the other important water lurks
I'm I think one of the things about
John's Gospel is that it's in some ways
like a great long poem and that images
get introduced early on and played with
a little differently in the middle and
brought to a kind of consummation at the
end so I think it's not a surprise that
water lurks here there's another image
that's deployed here toward the end of
the the the passage that we read when
Jesus and the disciples are engaged in
conversation about whether he has had
anything to eat yeah right yes and he
gives that a new we got right and that
that sets the stage for one of the next
things that we're going to be largest
chapter 6 chapter 6 and the bread of
life but here here the eating is
connected with doing the will of the
Father
so eating and doing rather than eating
and believing are connected or not and
remember how we had the conversation
about judgment right here with the Eids
back there in the other chapter so that
continues this theme as well and it also
points way ahead to the end of the
Gospel where the work is going to be
completed that same word is yeah I
noticed that for the first time as Lynn
read that is that that word that you get
it's completed at the end Jesus uses
here to talk about the completion of his
work right and and we'll see when we get
to the cross that that's the word that
Jesus uses for the completion of his
whole ministry exactly that same word so
bringing it all together in the cross
completes it
but is it completed right mm-hmm right
always always a tricky part yep and
we'll be seeing that when we come to
worry about the cross and resurrection
sounds good